And now it's the old scout master.
Strange thing,
Scouts do strange things.
I had a scout who decided that he would climb a tree
and cook his dinner up in the tree
And I had to tell him to come down
because the stakes were just too high.
You're gonna have to think about that one.
Sorry about that.
This is podcast number 355..
Come on,
Welcome back to the Scout Master podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Again, the publishing schedule is remaining as unpredictable as ever, as I pursue lots of things.
How's that for an explanation? I've always found it a little frustrating when people
apologize for not having done like blog posts or podcasts and go into lengthy explanations about
what's going on. Hey, everything's fine, I'm just busy with things. I haven't had a chance to sit
down and do a podcast that was worth publishing. I think this one is. So thanks for continuing to
find me, even though I am making it as difficult as possible. We'll get back on an even kill soon.
Before I go on, I want to tell you a story that happened over the weekend.
Wasn't I camping? Nope, I was at a wedding, a wedding for one of my old Eagle scouts.
It's one of the fringe benefits of hanging around for as long as we've hung around.
There are scouts who are well into their adulthood now who we kept in contact with, and we know their
parents, and we ended up getting invited to a wedding every so often. This is the third one
this year. It's been a little bit of an unusual year When it came time for them to exchange
vows. this is really touching. The bride went down the 12 points of the scout law
and listed those as reasons she was marrying the groom. Isn't that something? I wish I had recorded
it. I wish I had it written down and maybe, maybe I'll be able to get it someday and be able to share
it with you. But it was just such a sweet and touching moment to hear her talk about him being
trustworthy and loyal and helpful and friendly, And as soon as she got to a certain point
he kind of realized what she was doing, And as did the rest of us. there was a lot of scouts there.
The best man was a fellow that the groom knew from scouts, and a lot of the groom's men were
from scouts. It was just amazing, And so a lot of people recognized that she was talking about
the scout law And I was just so pleased, so touched and so grateful that that meant so
much, And it was a very, very special day for everyone involved And Ashley and Brian,
we send you our best wishes and our love. So, to move on in this podcast, I want to share with
you the result of an email discussion that I had with a fellow scout, or some time ago,
that I think you will find informative. So let's get started, shall we?
Ladies and gentlemen, the story you are about to see is true. The names have been changed to protect
the innocent.
There's something that you either have not heard before or was instantly recognizable,
And I put it here as kind of a lighthearted introduction to what is absolutely a serious
discussion about misbehavior, about incidents and all of those things that we really wish
never arrived at our doorstep as scouters, But these things are going to happen.
So let's take a look at an incident that I heard about really quite some time ago
and sort of use it to study how we react to scouts misbehaving. So let me read this to you.
After Weeblows visited our troop meeting the next morning, I got an email from one of the
adults involved with the pack. They said that the Weeblows reported back to them that
our scouts were using foul language And one of our scouts was looking up inappropriate images
on his phone and showing them to the Weeblows. Now that alone should send a cold chill down
the spine of every single scouter. The email goes on to say we were invited to a pack committee
meeting to discuss their concerns. Their position is that all scouts at any age need constant,
direct adult supervision at all times. I tried explaining the idea of youth leadership
and the patrol system, but they wouldn't really have any of it. I sat there while they told me
what a terrible leader I am and our troop is the worst they've ever seen. Unless we make changes,
they'll recommend their Weeblows look for a troop with a more adult involvement. I was later
contacted by our council to alert me that someone had reported the incident as a youth
protection violation and that they had to launch a full investigation. It was in their
hands now and to leave it up to them If you, if you didn't have a cold chill before, you
should be having one now. I got a call from the head of the chartering organization later on.
I was told that until things were resolved, all scouting activities were suspended
and all the adult volunteers from the troop in the pack needed to meet together with
two council representatives and go through youth protection training as a group. So
what do I do now? Oh man, this isn't funny. I understand that, but I laugh because boy do
I recognize that feeling. It's a very bad feeling. things are out of control and this
kind of incident is as unmanageable as a natural disaster, An earthquake, a typhoon,
a tornado, a hurricane, whatever you like. This is not what you would call a very
manageable situation. It's hard to fault anyone's actions here, right? I mean, you know
this is something that parents should rightfully be concerned about and
scouts should rightfully be concerned about. and I've got to say, you know,
probably needed to be elevated to the level where the council was looking in to make
sure that things were not just totally off the rails. But the nature of this
particular kind of misbehavior is kind of tabloid and salacious and I can
certainly understand the reaction. This sort of incident usually skews our
better judgment and perspective. Misusing cell phones, sharing inappropriate images
and the use of bad language- that is not something I would call unprecedented
amongst young people, and I can imagine similar scenarios and have actually
experienced similar scenarios in the past, where the inappropriate image that
was being shared was from a magazine and where the bad language could have
been profanities in music being shared on a Walkman. Remember Walkman, Remember
those. And then you could go back even further and talk about like comic books
and yeah. So anyway, look, this is not a sign that society is falling apart,
that you're a horrible leader, that your scouts are miserable,
misbehaving juvenile delinquents. This is the kind of thing
we ought to expect, frankly, and be prepared for, and that's what we're
going to discuss today. So the script that plays out when
this kind of thing happens is: there's an incident, there's
adult outrage and overreaction because you know something
must be done. So meetings are going to be held and
emails are going to be exchanged and authorities are going to be informed,
and we're going to be spend a great deal of time addressing a faulty
risk reward calculation based on a false
cause and effect relationship. That sounds pretty clinical, but let me explain
what I mean. The faulty reasoning begins
by assuming that an individual scout's indiscretion was caused
or enabled by a lack of supervision. Now, that could sometimes be the case,
but in reality it was caused by an individual scout
and could have happened really no matter the level of supervision.
So the attempt to mitigate the risk of a similar incident
by eliminating the possibility of all further incidents
like this is really kind of a classic logical fallacy,
and this kind of reaction unwittingly undercuts the scout oath and law
as to render it meaningless. One of my constant themes
is: the scout oath and law must mean something, and in incidents like these
it certainly does. and the work we do as scouters
in the broad goal of developing character in our scouts through the scout
oath and law is really the beginning and end of the way that
you address incidents like this. If we're to do our best for our scouts, we
really have to treat the principles of the oath and law as real
and have the highest expectations that they will be observed.
Now, to do this we also have to live with something
else that is going to sound clinical, but it's called cognitive
dissonance: Holding two opposing things in your mind at once. it's very
uncomfortable to do. okay, because we have to have the highest
expectations of behavior and at the same time we have to understand
that misbehavior is inevitable. and I'm going to tell you that not only is
misbehavior inevitable, in a way it is not unwelcome.
We all think having high expectations means what we want is
exemplary behavior in every instance, in every situation,
at all times. but we really don't want that, strangely enough.
Yes, what we really want is to know how to handle
misbehaviors. so, if you agree that misbehavior is inevitable
and it is, knowing how to react to it, to the mistakes and failures and even the
intentional wrongdoing that will sometimes happen
with scouts, is our opportunity to help them
internalize the meaning of the ideals in the scout oath and law.
So we have to be prepared to deal with all kinds of difficulties in misbehavior
and rather than making a huge deal out of them,
we want to reduce them to the smallest deal that we possibly can.
No, make no mistake, I am not saying that we ought to sanction
this sort of behavior, just that it would be foolish to think it doesn't exist
or to react out of all proportion when we discover that it does.
I'm not suggesting we have a permissive attitude or low expectations,
but just that we respond proportionately to bad behavior
in a way that achieves the ultimate goal that we have as scouters.
It's a continuous struggle to measure supervision
against granting the latitude required to grow and understand the scout oath and law.
We can't compel compliance if we expect the oath and law to have
meaning and lasting effect. listen to that again.
we can't compel complete compliance if we expect the oath and law to have
a lasting effect and have any meaning in the lives of our scouts.
We only have a lasting effect and these things only have meaning
if scouts internalize the ideals that we champion
voluntarily as a shared belief. voluntarily can't be compelled
to be a good scout. that's something you have to volunteer to do.
if that's not going to be absolutely compelled and it's going to be
voluntary, you're going to have problems and so you should be prepared for them
and have a way of dealing with them. so remember we talked about cognitive
dissonance. that should be happening in your brain
right now, because I'm saying the highest of expectations,
yet understanding that those expectations are not always going to be
met and that that's okay, not in a permissive atmosphere,
not in a way that sanctions any of those actions
or misbehaviors, but one that deals with them proportionately.
One of the possible reactions to the incident I described earlier is to
ratchet up adult involvement and supervision. but, like I said, that's
based on a false theory that a lack of supervision is responsible for what
happened and that to fix it we'll just ratchet up the supervision,
we'll make it airtight. this kind of thing can't ever happen again
and truly honestly, that kind of makes us
into hypocrites. and young people understand how hypocritical that kind of
thing is. when we say that they are trustworthy, loyal, helpful,
friendly, courteous, kind, obedient. when we say those things about scouts and
then we institute an atmosphere of airtight
supervision where they can never not be those things,
they understand that that's hypocritical because we're extending trust with one
hand and then, in an attempt to guarantee that
trust will never be broken, we're fencing them in with rules and intense
supervision on the other hand. I think scouts is probably the only
experience that's available to young people
where we can maintain this kind of cognitive dissonance
of having high expectations but expecting that we're going to deal with
things that do not reach those expectations,
being reasonably comfortable with that and making it
a character school for the development of good people.
now, when i've had problems- there have been plenty of problems in the 35 years
i've been involved with scouts- i'm reminded that scouting should be a
very safe place for scouts who fail and make mistakes
and even those, yes, who consciously do bad things.
hopefully we surround our scouts with compassionate, caring adults who have a
sense of proportion and experience in addressing
behavior problems in young people. now, like i said,
the reaction to an incident like this is definitely going to be beyond the scope
of your ability to control the, the fallout, and you're just
going to have to deal with that because this kind of thing
definitely upsets adults. it definitely sends a signal to the council that
they need to check up on things and make sure things are going okay
and i have to say in this incident, without going into a lot of detail,
that the council folks had a pretty good sense of proportion in their reaction
to this. but how would i react to a similar
incident personally? well, i don't know that i would be able to calm
down the weeblows parents and the people from the
pack, because i can certainly understand the
emotion to which they would react to an incident of this nature
and, honestly, my explanations and the way that i'm going to deal with it and
things like that. they may see some fault or some shortcomings in that
and they will choose whether or not they're going to associate themselves with my
troop based on things that are totally without the scope of my control,
because i'm certainly not going to change the nature
of the way that i work with scouts in such a drastic way
because of a single incident. now, if it was a pattern of misbehavior and
things like that, maybe i would make some considerations
and it would be wise to look into it and make sure that
i haven't been blind to what's going on. but the first reaction
out of the box is not going to be to heavily increase
the amount of adult supervision i have over my scouts.
if one of my scouts was doing things like it has been described in this, if
they're showing inappropriate images on their phone to younger
scouts, that would definitely be a cause for concern and it would be a
discussion i would have with the scouts parents.
i would be asking them in the scout's best interest,
not in an accusatory manner, but in the scout's best interest.
if this is a pattern of misbehavior that's coming to the surface
that they may not be aware of had there been similar incidents with other
scouts or schoolmates, this would be a good thing to talk with your son about.
you know, a significant age difference, if that was the case here,
raises concerns of potential physical misconduct because, as we've learned
in our youth protection training. this sort of thing could be classic grooming
behavior and i don't think that that particular
concern is totally misplaced in this context. as uncomfortable as that may be,
i think it's a good thing to discuss with the parents. i'd encourage them to be
aware of any change in behavior in their son that indicates they
have been seriously traumatized by the whole thing, because in my experience,
young people are very sensitive to public reprobation
once an incident like this comes to light and they could harm themselves because
of it. the other thing that i would want the parents of
this scout to understand: they have to assure me there's no
doubt that this kind of thing will not be repeated, and they
must have a clear understanding that i do not have very many options if it is-
and it will likely be- that their son will have to leave our troop.
so i would also be discussing this with a scout, hopefully with one of his
parents present and, if that can happen,
definitely with another adult, and with the scout i would discuss what our
appropriate response would be. not to go into detail
about that just now, but i am going to point you to an article that i wrote
about this, about constructive discipline
and, without going into detail, that one of the basic ideas that comes into play
here is that, as a scouter, i don't punish scouts.
i correct behavior and we have a response to whatever the direct
consequences of the behavior are, but we don't punish,
we don't sanction the scout. we don't suspend the scout for a given period of
time or anything like that. those are all punishments.
i'm not going to be involved in them. that is a parent's
prerogative. if they feel punishment is an order, it's for them to carry out.
if they choose to keep their scout out of being actively involved for a
period of time, that's up to them. what i tell them
is: you need to take whatever reaction you need to take with your child
and assure me that you've dealt with this in a way that guarantees
this won't be repeated. and if it is repeated, i have a reduced number of
options in reaction. so make sure to look at that article,
because i think it will help inform some of the ways that you deal with this.
so there are a couple of other issues to deal with when we're confronted with
an incident like this. now, the person who reported this
to me told me that they went and talked with their patrol leaders council
about it and the patrol leaders council decided to
institute some rules affecting cell phones and things,
and i don't think that they made a subjectively bad decision there, but it's
not where i would have gone personally.
on the upside, if you have some rules about cell phones
and scouts are reminded of them, that's probably a good thing.
on the downside, a rule substitutes policing for trust,
and policing usually causes more problems than it solves.
because if you say that these are the rules around cell phones, then you have
to police those rules and then you have to hand out punishments for breaches of
those rules and i and you just end up like in this spiral of
things that i don't personally like to get myself involved in.
and usually when these kind of rules are
instituted in a reaction to an incident, they get dismantled
in a few months because they become unmanageable.
when there is an incident of misbehavior that's real high profile
and all the families learn about it and it has its own little life out there.
as people talk about it and discuss it, inevitably people get back to me for an
explanation or a narrative and i tell them it's my
long practice to keep discussions with parents
about incidents like this in confidence. but they can rest assured, i've
discussed it with the scout and their parents and if they have any further
questions, they can address them to the scouts parents.
this is a family matter for them to deal with. if you want to know how they're
dealing with it, well, go ask them now. over the years, for one reason or
another, we've had groups of weeblos and weren't all that thrilled with their
troop and that means that their parents weren't all that thrilled
and they stayed away from us and they probably said things amongst themselves
and with other parents and in cub scouts. so i know what it feels like to be on
the outside of those types of things and it's
uncomfortable and it's not really great and it's probably unfair.
but it wasn't the end of the world, because if we're doing things well,
people will begin to understand that, in spite of the stories they've heard
to the contrary. so i know how unbelievably
horrible and chaotic it feels when you are in the midst of an incident like this
and, as it turns out, applying the ideals of the scout, oath and law
in the way that you react is a way to bring these to
a peaceful resolution and most of the time it is highlighted by
being kind- being kind to the scout who is having a bit of a problem,
being kind to the weeblos, parents and the people from the pack who are
possibly not treating you with the greatest kindness-
and not to forget to be kind to yourself as well.
don't beat yourself up over it. these kinds of things are going to happen
and, as i said a couple of times before, things will be out of the realm of
your control, as if there's been a natural disaster of
some kind, and the only thing you can do is really kind of pick up the pieces
and get started over again. well, i hope that helps. if you have a question,
a comment or a problem to solve, it's easy to get in touch with me.
email me at clark at scoutmastercgcom. and before i go today, i want to thank
all the people who make this possible, all of the backers and the patrons.
thank you for lending some financial support to scoutmastercgcom.
it is truly appreciated, and all that remains for today's podcast is for us to
hear from our founder, Sir Robert Baden Powell. Sir Robert,
good luck to you and good camping, why? thank you, sir,
until next time, everyone.